[Music]
good morning everybody gonna say good
morning
it is monday morning and i thought i
would make a video today about
what i eat in a day but also includes
some easy recipes that i've made for
years and years for anybody who maybe is
like
starting off in cooking because i think
these are really good
easy to do and also fun to explore
sort of recipes that are healthy that
are quick to make
and really don't require that much time
at all so we're gonna start
with breakfast and i'm very hungry
because i've been waiting to film this
part
and haven't eaten breakfast yet
so for breakfast i usually eat something
that i can make super quickly
eat pretty easily and non-messily
and will basically keep me full until
lunchtime so these are my overnight oats
cue the montage where i show you how to
make it in this i put oats and chia
and then a milk of your choice i just
drink whole milk
and then a sweetener usually honey or
maple syrup today i used maple syrup
because it's got that fall vibe
and then i also add a teeny tiny bit of
vanilla for flavor
so what i usually do with this i mix it
up
a little bit because the oats have sunk
into the bottom
this is basically like an apple jam
sauce sort of thing uh these
apples came from when i made my apple
cider and apple juice
which i made in this video right there
but yeah i had a lot of apples left over
they were all spiced and i was like i
could put them on yogurt or something
so i'm gonna put these on top today when
i eat this i usually do like to put
something on top so today it's apples
because
fall vibes but you can put berries
strawberries blackberries raspberries
blueberries
you can also put like a jam sometimes
like sometimes i'll just buy
jam at the store and just put it on top
you can also put dried fruits and dried
nuts it's a very versatile thing it's
kind of like
cold oatmeal but more refreshing and
better
and my mouth is watering now because i'm
very hungry
time to eat it's time to eat
i'm gonna eat my breakfast
yeah so when i'm not drinking coffee
because my anxiety is high
then i'll usually make a big mug of tea
i like using the lipton decaffeinated
one just because it's a very standard
black tea that's decaf
add a little bit of sugar a little bit
of milk and then i sip on that all
morning while i do my morning work
now let's eat some of this the apple's
really good
the apple definitely like brings it that
fall vibes
i know that this breakfast is not
exactly the most aesthetic
or visually pleasing because at the end
it's just like white-ish mush
but it is really tasty it's super easy
to do
and it's very refreshing to eat good
breakfast option in my opinion
[Music]
it's time for lunch it's 12 30 p.m
and now i'm gonna make lunch so today on
the menu
i'm going to make a tofu bowl this is
also a very good
food for like hot weather and also a
very healthy one
in case i want to eat something that's
not that heavy
but still tastes super super good so i'm
going to show you how i do that
so these are all the things that you
need to make the tofu bowl
you need tofu rice you need some green
onions
soy sauce and then these are optional
but this is how i like to make it
i've got some roasted sesame seaweed
this one i just got from costco
but you can use kind of any seaweed that
you like from katsuogushi which is like
bonito flakes i guess bonito flakes
you can also find this the asian market
and then this is
which like this thing is such a staple
in japanese cooking that i do recommend
having this if you want to make lots of
different
japanese recipes but you don't have to
the beauty of this bowl is you can kind
of flavor it however you want
if you have some general asian flavors
so first we're going to start off with
rice i made a bunch of rice yesterday
and i made it in my zojirushi rice
cooker in terms of how to make rice
there's a ton of other youtube videos to
follow but really
just get yourself a rice cooker they're
not that expensive
and then next we're gonna do the tofu so
i'm not gonna use all of the tofu
for one serving i usually do just like a
half block of tofu
so i'm gonna cut it and drain the water
that's inside
so that the water doesn't go everywhere
i'm gonna store the other half in a
little container
you can keep tofu for a couple of days
in the fridge
i just like to add water to it so that
it stays pretty moist
kind of just like that so the next thing
you're going to do is you're just going
to crumble this tofu
into the rice thing and really there's
no rhyme or reason
you just kind of crumble it with your
hands uh tofu is a really good source of
protein
and it's a very clean protein too tofu
a lot of people are intimidated by
because the flavor
itself is like there's not that much
flavor i mean it does have flavor
but tofu really shines when you add
other flavors to it and that's how you
cook tofu
so i'm going to make a little sauce for
this i've got about 1 tablespoon of soy
sauce if you don't like
things to be that salty then i recommend
going less i'm also gonna do one
tablespoon
of this otsuyu dashi stock this really
has that
uh what american people like to call
umami
but really it's just it's just fish
stock it's
it's fish i'm gonna add like half a
tablespoon of sesame oil
i kind of want to add a little bit of
spice to this so i'm actually gonna make
some sriracha
you know what's even better sambal sauce
which is also made by the same company
so i'm gonna
actually just do some sambal this is
really just up to you
however spicy you want it i'm gonna do
like that much if you can see that
because i just want it to be a hint of
spicy and then you're basically just
gonna mix it up
it's super duper easy you can taste the
sauce before it goes into the bowl
to taste whether you like it or not
that's pretty good i would actually
maybe even do like a little less of the
sesame because it's a very overpowering
uh flavor that's done you don't need
that much sauce just this much
and then i'm just gonna pour it all over
and then kind of coat the rice and the
tofu
with this sauce and then next and
finally are the toppings for green
onions make sure you wash it because
there's
dirt and stuff in there and if it's not
dirt then it's
germs from other people and stuff and
especially during cover time you should
probably wash your veggies
okay just gonna cut off the ends
and then cut it in half so that you can
just do half the work
i'm actually going to put that in last
because i think the color of it's going
to look really nice
and it's always good to have a little
bit of green in an otherwise very beige
food
so next i'm gonna put the seaweed in i'm
just gonna cut
a few like they're they come in sheets
like this and then i'm basically gonna
make
flakes by cutting them up like this you
just cut it directly
into your bowl see now that's already
got some color it's looking good
next i'm gonna add these bonito flakes
bonito is just a type of fish
uh in japanese it's called katsuo and
these are just flakes that look like
this
and i like adding it because it's
another layer of flavor and now that
we've got all those toppings
then it's green onions time
i'm actually gonna add a little bit of
sesame seeds as well
because i put sesame oil in it and i
feel like i'm going for like a sesame
sort of thing
the seaweed also has sesame so not a
whole lot
just a little sprinkle and then we're
done
this is the completed product it looks
super delicious i eat this when i'm
feeling lazy to cook
i want something cool but filling to eat
i want protein and i want carbs and i
want
any of the other vegetables that you put
on top
that was delicious it's salty it's a
little bit
spicy it's very refreshing still there's
a lot of different textures
and flavors and it's tofu it's tofu but
like just really good tofu i've been
making this for years but over the years
i think i've figured out
what flavors i like in this and then
also have layered the toppings on it
i've put kimchi on top of this before
you can put like leftover
meats on top of this if you want
leftover veggies
it's really just kind of whatever you
want it to be and you can really just
experiment with different spices and
flavors in your kitchen
to make it yours
[Music]
that was a very good lunch i finished
all of it i'm pretty full generally for
lunch i like to eat things that are not
that
heavy because i don't want a food coma
after lunch because i still have
an afternoon of things to do so i tend
to kind of eat on the lighter side
that means eating a pretty balanced meal
which i kind of try to do for most
lunches and dinners of having
good mix of carbs protein fibers other
things in that food pyramid and then
other
things for just flavor too i like making
food i make food basically every meal
with scott and so we both really enjoy
cooking
i think we've learned a lot of what
there is to know about cooking on the
internet
and in san diego we're very fortunate to
have all these kinds of
grocery stores and lots of great
ingredients and stuff
it's a very important part of me to
nourish my body with the right things
and also
to take care of it so that i can do what
i want to do in life
another thing that i think about a lot
in making food is understanding the
environmental impact that i have on food
yes i still do eat meat because it's a
important part of my diet but not nearly
as much
so food like tofu that doesn't create as
much greenhouse gases
to contribute to climate change is
really important and this is where i
want to thank the sponsor of today's
video
sunrun climate change is definitely
happening especially in california where
we have wildfires
all the freaking time and the current
energy system as we've seen it
uh has a ton of unknown and so you can't
predict how often rates might climb
or if a storm is going to come and if
you're going to lose power and for how
long
but the one thing that is super reliable
though is that the sun will rise
each day and with sun runs rechargeable
battery systems
you have control over the energy that
you consume now and
also in the future not to mention just
solar energy just completely makes sense
like why were we
going through all of the arcane ways of
getting energy
when there is a completely sustainable
renewable
source of energy in the sky every day
and day
and so with sunroom the combination of
solar plus battery keeps the lights on
during blackouts
because you're not tied to the grid you
can also choose to back up whatever you
want so you can either choose to back up
your entire home or
just the essentials with sunrun you can
choose your solar plans services
and discounts so you can choose a plan
that fits well for your needs
also sunrun is your guide they're
experts in solar energy and so they're
incredibly knowledgeable
they're very optimistic about using
reusable energy sources in the future
and they're incredibly ambitious they're
a company that's really turned it around
for solar energy so if you're interested
in learning more about sun run and
reusable energy through solar
then visit the link in the description
box down below and thank you so much to
sunrun for sponsoring
it's got snacks what are we eating scott
hairs that come in skirts pears that
come in skirts
these always come in the oh the pears
that come in diapers
fiber do you think snacks are an
important part of a daily diet
[Music]
you don't want it
will benny eat it
[Music]
it's dinner time why i did that i do not
know
for dinner today we're making a meal
that scott and i
often often have it's one of the first
kind of regular meals that we started to
have when we graduated college it's one
of the easiest things it's still like
comfort food to us
but we're basically gonna make baked
chicken and veggies
super yummy so let's do it first thing
you're gonna do is set the oven to 425
take the chicken out of the pack i'm
gonna use drumsticks i also use sides
for this recipe
you could also use white meat like
breast or something for example but
i like using dark meat suited for this
and i'm just gonna use three drumsticks
so we're gonna wash them
then i'm just gonna pop them dry i ended
up just deciding to use all of them
because why not
it's worth it to just make a bunch of
chicken at once and then just have
leftovers than just eating to cook many
more times you know
make sure you wash your hands and now
i'm basically just gonna flavor the
chicken so
first i'm gonna put some apple cider
vinegar probably like
two tablespoons and then i'm also gonna
add one tablespoon of olive oil
as far as spices go i'm gonna keep it
pretty simple i'm gonna use
laurie's garlic salt this has been a
staple in her kitchen for many years
but we just buy this at costco honestly
this chicken is fine just with the
garlic salt
i'm going to add a couple of other
things in here but this makes cooking
very very easy so i'm going to add about
one tablespoon into here
next i'm just gonna add some sage and
that also
that's probably gonna be like a quarter
of a teaspoon
some cayenne pepper cayenne really is
pretty spicy so i like to add it even
just a little bit
even if you don't like spice because it
wakes up the flavors but also if you
like spicy you can just add more for
this i'm gonna do like
one two three four and so now before i
mix i'm actually just gonna get the pan
ready so that while my hands are dirty i
can do two things at once
so i just took one of these like glass
casserole dishes and put some aluminum
foil on it
it's just the easiest way to like clean
up right afterwards because then the
stuff won't get onto the pan itself so
now i'm just gonna mix it with my hands
best part about this dish is that this
is a great place to experiment with
different spices so
if you go to the spice aisle at your
local supermarket or your market or
whatever
and then just experiment with lots of
different flavors and dry roads
honestly this dish is really kind of how
we learned about how to use
certain savory spices and it's been
pretty eye opening so now it's all mixed
and now i'm just gonna line it on the
pan
i'm gonna take the rest of the sauce and
just kind of drizzle it over everything
and that's it your chicken is ready to
go into the oven
at 4 25 i usually do it for like 20
minutes on one side
open the oven and then flip it and do
another 20 minutes so
the oven's ready so i'm going to pop
these in
next up we're going to do these rainbow
carrots i really like rainbow carrots it
just
adds a lot of color to a dish and they
just taste like regular carrot now i'm
not going to peel them because i think a
lot of the flavor
is in the skin but i will wash them and
chop them up so now i'm just chopping
off the ends of
all the carrots and now i'm going to cut
them into bite
sized pieces be careful when you're
cutting
kind of just into like that size shape
so now that these are all cut and
beautiful
i'm just gonna add some rosemary salt
and olive oil and just toss them
oh and also pepper pepper pepper
and now all you gotta do is just toss it
and then just
put all of your carrots onto the pan and
then
these basically just go into the oven
with your chicken
you do have to keep an eye on these
because these don't cook for as long as
a chicken
but you can just kind of throw them in
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right everyone well i hope you liked
that video and all the recipes that i
shared
let me know if you want another video
like this maybe to share some of my
japanese recipes or anything else let me
know in the comments down below
make sure to hit the subscribe button if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more from me
i hope you all are doing well and i will
see you next time
bye